March 10th was a clear morning Ethiopian
Airlines flight 302 had just left Addis
Ababa for Nairobi when it plummeted
nose-first into a field outside the
Ethiopian capital a disaster that killed
all 157 people on board a preliminary
report now rules out human error as the
cause of the tragedy suggesting the crew
did everything in their power to avoid
the crash the crew performing all the
procedures repeatedly provided by the
manufacturer but was not able to control
their craft the Boeing 737 max aid
reportedly experienced erratic climbs
and descents shortly after takeoff a
situation similar to the one preceding
the crash of Lion Air flight six one Oh
in October which killed a hundred and
eighty-nine people with the night air
accident because number one it's the
same airplane model brand new on the
other hand the flight the duration of
the flights also is almost similar our
flight was six months six minutes very
short applied scrutiny is centered on an
anti stall system that has repeatedly
given pilots problems it's designed to
automatically lower the aircraft's nose
if it detects a stall or loss of
airspeed anxious to win back public
trust in its products boeing announced
last week it had reprogrammed the
software on the 737 max to stop the anti
stall system from triggering but the US
Federal Aviation Administration advised
Boeing to keep working on the proposed
fix before submitting the system for
review with this fastest-selling plane
grounded boeing isn't only facing
increasing reputational issues analysts
say a lengthy delay could cut the
company's revenues by billions
Christophe Cobre from DW business is
following the story and joins me now for
more in the studio so Christophe kind of
a damning report isn't it so what does
this initial report on the Ethiopian
Airlines crash mean for Boeing well
there is
certainly a bad aspect to it but also a
someone a somewhat good aspect to it I
got to that in the second first day bad
aspect certainly here is that this
automated anti-stall system which
apparently is reliant only on one sensor
is not reliable and it also sheds a
light on Boeing how it introduced this
737 max years to its customers
essentially saying this is just the
newest version of a long-established
plane when in fact it wasn't it was a
brand new plane with a lot of changes
done to it which pilots were not
informed about because and and there's
many people many pilots saying well we
needed training for this boeing could
have offered training but often didn't
because that would have meant extra cost
to their customers something that boeing
didn't want them to consider these
somewhat somewhat good aspect here is
that engineers at Boeing now can almost
entirely rule out that the cause of the
second crash was a different one than
the one in October which means they are
most likely not forced to conduct
another thorough time-consuming
investigation on where this this fault
might have been well this is of course
you know horrible it's appalling you
know so many people have lost their
lives over these awesome yeah and you
know perhaps the company should have
been aware of this how are they reacted
to these findings there hasn't been much
of a reaction so far obviously this is a
sensitive issue to Boeing they don't
want to jump to conclusions once there
is a say a bigger picture public he
published here so the company said it
would study the report by the Ethiopian
authorities once it comes out which
people expect will be on fighting
alright so they're gonna study the
report but now they're really gonna have
to do something what would it take for
Boeing to be able to get its 737 max in
the arrogant or is that already out of
the question well it needs to get
regulators stamp of approval that the
737 max serious is a safe aircraft and
for that it needs to get the changes to
this automated flight flight system
certified now Boeing said that on
Wednesday they successfully conducted
tests of this updated
flight system the anti-stall system now
the Federal Aviation Administration
needs to certify this update however it
might be more difficult to get the
thumbs-up here then one might think
because the FAA just said on Wednesday
it is forming an international team to
not only review this automated
anti-stall system and the update for it
but the safety of the 737 max series in
general I mean this all sounds pretty
damaging for Boeing what is the impact
of it the impact is huge so far I mean
these more than 300 737 max planes are
grounded they're not generating any
revenues for the for the companies that
own them now Boeing is preparing for
possible claims of damages by these
companies that say alright we're not
earning any money with your jets and
this is your fault plus the 737 max is
Boeing's top-selling aircraft there are
about 5,000 to have been ordered by by
companies and they're really banking
heavily on this jet now if more airlines
and more customers should lose faith in
this aircraft the damage would be even
bigger
all right DW is Christophe Gober many
thanks indeed